because it's a fantastic investment and
you're the only one who's interested for
months they denied there were problems
you're doing yourself for incredible
disservice as a so-called journalists
with this nonsense and innuendos after
claims of corruption at one of the UK's
largest unions Labor's biggest donor
I don't believe I don't well don't get
in my face step don't get in my way Len
McCluskey is now retired as unite
General Secretary there is no suggestion
of wrongdoing on his part but his
successor has acted very differently
Sharon Graham rarely gives interviews
but she ran for the top job on a promise
to investigate if necessary obviously if
there was anything awry on that then I
would deal with that and she has
commissioning two reports which found
evidence of potential criminality
they're now being handed to the police
officers raided this building unites
London headquarters in April as part of
a fraud bribery and money laundering
investigation now police also have
access to these two independent reports
to help inform their work and I'm told
by One Source they contain details of
pricing and overcharging that would make
your eyes bleed
one report looked into the tens of
millions of pounds wasted on the unions
vastly over Budget Hotel and Conference
Center in Birmingham the development was
originally supposed to cost around 7
million pounds later rising to 57
million the final cost is now north of
98 million pounds one contractor was
found to have quoted around 90 000
pounds for work but was eventually paid
1.2 million an unexplained increase of 1
300 percent
the conservatives have written to labor
urging them to stop accepting money from
the union and return the 750 000 pounds
the party has received since the police
raid I look forward to the police doing
uh their work but the fact that Sharon
Graham has done this uh work has handed
it over the police I think shows that
the change that's happening in unite the
Union
a unite spokesperson has told Sky News
the general secretary is committed to
doing all in her power to recoup any
monies lost by all means necessary and
holding anyone responsible to account
whatever police do next if these reports
are right it seems unlikely that unite
will ever be able to fully recover the
millions of members money now missing
Joe Pike Sky News